President Trump says he will name his
Supreme Court nominee one week from
today
he's been courting key senators looking
for votes to support his replacement for
retiring Justice Anthony Kennedy one
Republican moderate senator Susan
Collins drew a sharp line yesterday on
the issue of abortion rights I would not
support a nominee who demonstrated
hostility to roe v wade because Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning good morning and Senator Collins
said that the president told her in
private conversations that he would not
question potential nominees about roe
v-- wade in fact on his way to
Bedminster New Jersey the president said
that it would be inappropriate to
discuss roe v-- wade with these nominees
CBS News has confirmed that potential
candidates did not go to bed Minster
over the weekend as the president hinted
might happen and he has mentioned that
he will consider more than a handful of
potential nominees CBS News has learned
that DC Circuit Court Judge bread
Cavanaugh and Chicago Circuit Court
Judge Amy Kony Barrett are currently the
leading contenders for an appointment to
the High Court the White House says
President Trump discussed potential
nominees within House Counsel over the
weekend don McGann and the president has
said that the interviews begin in
earnest today Gale all right got it
Nancy thank you